salud en directo américa de france 24 y
ya está conmigo en el estudio marina
sardina marina bienvenida buena mañana
de martes vamos a hablar de reino unido
porque en ese país se aprobó una nueva
vacuna contra el coronavirus diseñada
para dos cosas tratar este virus
original y la variante omicron así de
raúl buenos días rines se convierte en
el primer país en aprobar esta vacuna
doble es una dosis de refuerzo para los
mayores de 50 años que se comenzarán a
aplicar el próximo otoño sobre a finales
de septiembre se trata de un nuevo suero
desarrollado por el laboratorio
estadounidense moderna denominado como
vacuna bivalente puesto que ataca tanto
a la cepa original del cobi 19 como a la
primera variante de omicron la ve a uno
que se detectó por primera vez en
noviembre recordemos que según la
organización mundial de la salud la
última oleada de coronavirus ha sido
impulsada por la variante micro b5
responsable de cerca de más del 70% de
los contagios a nivel mundial y es que
desde la aparición del cobi 19 el
patógeno pues ha estado mutando
sustancialmente dando pie a nuevas
variantes
pueden esquivar algunas de nuestras
defensas inmunológicas elevando también
el número de contagios el objetivo de la
nueva vacuna es ayudar a la protección
contra la enfermedad a medida que el
virus sigue la evolución y la
farmacéutica espera también raúl que
nuevos países autoricen su uso pues
relativamente pronto marina hablemos del
funcionamiento cómo funciona una vacuna
bivalente bueno este suero desarrollado
por modernas provoca una respuesta
inmune contra dos antígenos diferentes
dos variantes de un mismo virus lo que
hace es que codifican dos versiones de
la proteína de la punta del sars kof 2 a
través de la tecnología de rn mensajero
cambiando parte de la molécula de
información poniendo otra molécula de
información una que está dirigida a la
cepa original y otra a la cepa de
omicron y todo en una misma dosis hasta
ahora las vacunas de refuerzo de
refuerzo actuales contra el cob y 19 se
dirigen a tratar el virus de forma
original al virus original no se
consideraban monovalentes en las pruebas
hechas contra las variantes más
recientes de omicron la bea 4 y la bea 5
también mostraron niveles más altos de
protección cuando se tenía esta vacuna
actualizada y esto fue lo que dijo el
director general de moderna en reino
unido
una vez que el virus haya mutado de
nuevo podemos crear otra secuencia
podemos tener lista otra secuencia de
adn mensajero y formularla entonces
dependiendo a donde vaya el virus y de
la cantidad de enfermedad que esté
causando podemos poner esa además de
esta vacuna o podemos sustituirla y
volver a ella así que somos capaces de
adaptar muy rápidamente la vacuna a este
virus tan progresivo schwarz bueno
marina un buen avance entonces para este
virus del cobi 19 atacar la mayor
cantidad de variantes posibles pero
cambiamos ahora de información marina
nos vamos a eeuu porque las autoridades
sanitarias ya identificaron el virus que
causa la poliomielitis en agua en las
aguas recibía residuales de la ciudad de
nueva york si raúl las autoridades están
alertando sobre un posible caso de
transmisión su emisión local puesto que
se detectó ya como contamos también hace
un mes un paciente esté registrado
positivo por polio durante la primera
mitad del siglo 20 la polio mielitis
aterrorizó a los padres de todo el mundo
y ahora estos nuevos brotes en países
como israel reino unido o eeuu están
alarmando a las autoridades sanitarias
que están a los padres a vacunar a sus
hijos especialmente a los menores de 5
años puesto que estos son los más
afectados por la enfermedad y lo hacen
como estrategia de prevención recordemos
que la polio es una enfermedad
contagiosa que se transmite de persona a
persona normalmente cuando la persona
entra en contacto con las heces de una
persona infectada y luego se toca la
boca por ejemplo o en menor frecuencia
puede también transmitirse a través de
las partículas de las gotas de saliva al
estornudar y en contacto muy es muy
estrecho esto fue lo que nos dijo el
organismo estatal de salud de nueva
york'
el riesgo para los neoyorquinos es real
pero la defensa es muy simple vacunarse
contra la poliomielitis con la
poliomielitis circulando en nuestras
comunidades simplemente no hay nada más
esencial que vacunar a nuestros niños
para protegerlos de este virus
el 75% de las personas contagiadas por
poliomielitis suelen ser asintomáticas
pero pueden transmitir el virus incluso
sin estar enfermas al sin presentar
síntomas de la enfermedad como decíamos
de estas dolencias suelen ser leves
similares a una gripe pero pueden tardar
hasta 30 días en aparecer sus síntomas
también pueden causar parálisis
irreversible e incluso la muerte
recordemos que si bien no existe una
cura para esta enfermedad si ya que hay
una vacuna de prevención la vacuna
antipoliomielítica inactivada que es la
única que se administra en eeuu desde el
año 2000 el suero sigue siendo una
sesión administrando de una primera
dosis cuando los bebés tienen 2 meses de
edad una segunda dosis cuando tienen 4
meses y después de eso una dosis de
protección a los 6 meses de edad para
tener una protección de alrededor 90% de
protección y después a los 4 años ya
aplica una cuarta dosis para garantizar
una protección de por vida marina como
siempre muchísimas gracias por toda la
información de salud nos vemos mañana
con más pasamos a saludar a nuestro
segundo invitado del día